but I guess I also realize now
um I definitely do not enjoy driving I
am I am not a oh really I am not a
driver like I I thought you know this
would this would be the big test because
me driving in America I had to like
Drive
to Lake Tahoe which was a Pleasant Drive
uh like four hours [__] hell yeah
that's actually so that's an average
average
yeah but like I mean like Tahoe was a
very very beautiful area that kind of
area is very beautiful and you know I
kind of like wait what card did you run
uh I rented an SUV not a not a [__]
Jeep or whatever yeah it wasn't a
massive Jeep just just a normal SUV like
a nice I just feel like America I get a
bit kind of big car culture a little bit
because I'm like yeah it feels nice you
got the big room yeah music glaring AC
do you know what I got what country
music as soon as we got to the Lake
Tahoe as soon as we got to like the like
the Lake Tahoe area the nature like
[__] Nature Valley everywhere and uh
yeah uh dinos was like put on some
country music I'm like Titus I'm not
[__] putting on country music and he
was like give me give me the phone and
he put it on and uh you know started off
um
started off with the classics Country
Road and then started putting on some
other stuff I've never heard of and I'm
like
[__] no I kind of get this now [__] I'm
open to all sorts of music country is
one that I just can't country under any
other circumstance I'm like no get the
[__] out of here but driving driving on
actual country roads in America I'm like
okay actually kind of a Vibe actually
okay so why didn't you like driving then
stressful
maybe it's like but you're like out in
the middle of
no stressed about it I get if you're in
like the middle of this of the sea in
this traffic roundabouts you just go
straight on top it's look it's it's
stressful because okay I think this is
like my I think this is like an ADHD
thing but I just feel like they're uh
I'm it might be it's it's the thought of
being in a situation where if I [__] up
I die right
what do you mean why is that funny why
is that funny
just why is that funny there's a lot of
things that could apply to yeah but like
and then that's half the things you do
in life right no okay no when you're
driving it's like riding a bicycle
oh no you never you're barely ever going
fast enough on the bicycle to Warrant
okay if I [__] up there's a big
possibility I could die most of the time
if you're on a bicycle uh you the worst
that could happen is that you fall over
or something right yeah
okay look do you feel that way when you
cross the road no no okay okay when you
cross the roads like if I just stop
right now and a car hits me I could die
no no when you cross the road that is
not comparable to driving a car when you
ride the bike there's an amount of risk
that you take on daily as a human being
and driving probably gives you a little
bit more rooms yes and driving the thing
about driving it is it is a constant you
have to be like at least for me you have
to be mentally just on yeah makes me
click because if you can't just like I
would hope so yeah yeah you can't just
like I guess just zone out when you're
driving uh completely obviously
hopefully uh otherwise you put yourself
and all your passengers at risk so for
me I just like being mentally on and
being aware of my mirrors and just being
aware that you know I'm constantly
following the road following the road
rules even on like an empty road uh it's
actually especially on a country road
because country roads are normally a bit
more windier a bit more control needed
so I'm like it's just a lot of time
where I need to be mentally on for a
very long period of time are you the
kind of person that hates it when
someone is talking to you while you're
driving
you can't hold a conversation while
you're driving no I would rather someone
talk to me yeah but but as as long as I
don't have to talk back which is what I
mean which is which is which is why me
well that's not quite a conversation
it's like like you just gone she's like
there's literally no difference to you
just listening to a podcast at that
point
which is why I very much enjoyed uh
driving with Sydney because she can like
just she can talk my ear off and I'm
like that's that's interesting that's
interesting and it's just that's just
like that's great
I'm actually that's the thing I am
actually listening it's it's keeping me
attentive and aware but not enough where
I need to like put thoughts into my like
a conversation back and everything like
that that's like my perfect drive you
know but it's just yeah it's just to me
I don't know if this is a me thing it's
just very mentally taxing to be that
switched on for that long amount of time
even if it's a very beautiful area I
mean four hours is a long drive bro like
yeah I mean for Americans make it look
easy but I don't know everyone else
that's a long [__] drive yeah I don't
I don't know how I don't know how
Americans do it but yeah me driving I
realize yeah I get like there's always
this small anxiety in in me I don't know
if this is me thing I'm I'm saying this
not to you guys I'm saying this to you
guys to be like this
you know we joke about Americans love
driving and doing it but I think I've
met a fair amount of Americans who are
like I just wish I didn't have to drive
yeah oh Aki hates it yeah yeah she's
like I have to because otherwise I can't
[__] get anywhere yeah I I would
under any other circumstance uh give me
the passage give me the passenger seat
every time if if I have the choice of
being a passenger or getting the freedom
to drive myself I will choose being a
passenger uh passenger every single time
um because yeah it's just I there's this
anxiety feeling that I can never get rid
of no matter what when I'm driving and
that's just that feeling of having to be
mentally switched on uh no matter what
the situation music helps me music helps
you drive yeah yeah same country music
yeah no
I mean if it's the only thing available
I'll listen to it you know next time if
we ever go to an America trip where we
go out to the Wilderness I swear to God
I swear to God Try It Out Try It Out uh
you might you might you might discover
something about yourself because I've
heard a couple of bangers but like I
don't think I could sit for like an
entire four-hour road trip just
listening it's it's it's it's a it's
about the vibe you know sometimes
sometimes it's like drifting and
eurobeat you know yeah sometimes you
just find a situation or an environment
where you put on the right track and
then suddenly everything just clicks
together you know I feel like if
everyone gets nervous when you're
driving in Europe it comes on
it's like oh [__] not an imitation is it
getting faster or is it just me yeah
you know sometimes yeah yeah I mean
that's issue with like every piece of
music genre you know sometimes you'll
find the perfect music genre for the
perfect Vibe and even if you're not a
fan of that genre you kind of like [__]
with it at that particular moment in
time um I'm sure there are other moments
that I'm like kind of like blanking on
right now but yeah country music on
country roads Sun who knew actually
[__] works that is true like
depending on what I'm listening to while
I'm driving my mood is completely
different if I'm I never put on like
punk music when I'm driving yeah because
I just get so angry yeah like every
small tiny little thing like this guy
just like slightly deviated into my lane
I'm just like
[__] you do you know you know what uh do
you know what music genre I've kind of
like fallen out of
kind of I don't know if it's like
falling out is the right word but just
Lo-Fi what is the what is the what is
the right mood or what is the right
situation to ever put like it's it's
modern day elevator music it is it's
just music yeah yeah you know people
people just it's it's good background
noise that I think everyone is agreeable
on and that it's not annoying it's good
it's good homework music if you're just
like sitting at your desk and you just
need some kind of noise in the
background yeah like it's just like
ambient music like it's just it's just
noise in the back it's just the most
inoffensive I I get Lo-Fi because it's
the most inoffensive kind of music you
can put no one's going to complain about
Lo-Fi except for me right now but I've
somehow found a way to explain about it
okay the reason is okay the reason is
every time like me and Cindy have people
over to uh to our house oh yeah Sydney
puts Lo-Fi on and it's it's it's
happened enough times now where I'm like
Sydney why are you putting this on yeah
and um and she's just like oh she's wish
who's gonna complain about Lo-Fi and I'm
Sydney
I am could you do this every single time
the conversation feel like you're stale
yeah you feel like it's like I'm bored
yeah exactly right cut that [__] off put
on some country right now I'm just like
Sydney why I hope thing on me yeah
Sydney why uh why are you being scared
right now and I'm lying she's like what
are you talking about and I'm like why
are you being so scared to put on your
own Taste of Music in music yeah you
know what I mean because like if you go
around a house and people put Lo-Fi on
what I think is why are you scared to
show me your actual music taste yeah
true why are you not putting on your
actual Spotify playlist here come on
who's gonna get judged yeah yeah don't
be a [__] all right do you guys have a
music playlist to put on when there are
people around or do you just have I play
the same five songs for everything gone
I I I actually I actually realized
recently uh because I was also the guy
where I'm just like I don't want to
[__] scare the hoes like showing all
these like weirdos
oh
all right with all the weird [__] that I
listened to privately so yeah yeah so I
was always the dealer I'm just like
Everyone likes Lo-Fi I'll just put on
some Lo-Fi yeah but now I'm just getting
to the point where I've listened to so
much Lo-Fi and I've listened to so much
Lo-Fi in YouTube videos where I'm like
every time I put it on I just feel like
I'm watching a YouTube essay yeah
I just get into the YouTube essay yeah
like this is kind of boring I found out
though one playlist that works every
time is an 80s playlist yeah yeah 80s
music like you put on some [__]
Michael Jackson you put on some like you
know classic like 80s rock 80s like
disco stuff like you know some Earth
Wind and Fire yeah Banger everyone
everyone enjoys that yeah because
because the thing I realized is
um you know in terms of like you know
sitting right in the right move for like
a house party or a house Gathering or
something you put on Lo-Fi No One's
Gonna complain about it but the music
isn't gonna bring anything for the vibe
exactly it's not gonna do anything it's
just it's just a silence filler yeah
that's it uh and you know sometimes
sometimes you're feeling you're feeling
brave enough to actually put on your you
know your real your real Spotify
playlists I I I've noticed Connor you're
an exception because you're the beeps
and boops guys normally what I've
noticed people have like two levels they
have their surface level Spotify
playlist and then they have their this
is the [__] I listen to in private and
No One's Gonna know what this playlist
is
because I realized I I realized
unintentionally I have those playlists
as well when I've had when I've hosted
enough parties where I'm like I wanna I
wanna put on things that is my taste but
at least I think that I think people
will enjoy you know you know that's one
thing I hate about like Discord is that
like if you're listening to Spotify on
your computer on your Discord it says
like you know blah blah is playing
Spotify and then if you go over to it
you can see what song they're listening
to and I've had so many instances where
I'm just like chilling out listening to
my real playlist yeah um and I've had
people just message you being like what
the [__] are you listening to what is
this [__] and I'm like stop judging me
get out of my life this is me time right
now stay out of it don't judge I've
never felt the need for another playlist
I'm like who doesn't want to listen to
Daft Punk
level above Lo-Fi
in terms of you can play it in any
situation people be like yes you're like
Tame Impala like who's gonna listen to
Life one of those songs be like God I
can't stand this I'm like no that one
likes the sound of it exactly the
background I pick beeps and boobs I know
what sounds good in a background yeah
yeah like Connor's like they're they're
he kind of has five songs that he uses
for every single occasion no matter what
it is yeah yeah I mean you know Janelle
was like what was really fun actually
was uh picking
picking my wedding song playlist that
was actually the most fun I've ever had
like making a playlist uh because yeah I
don't know
walking down the aisle
okay that wasn't part of the playlist
that was something that just kind of
like clicked into place I think uh it's
good it's good so it's so good it's so
gone Sydney
yeah I mean I mean you know it's I think
if that didn't get meme to [__]
it'd be a very powerful it is a very
powerful piece and uh we decided on that
before it became a big meme I guess yeah
yeah before it became a big meme so it I
mean it is a very powerful piece I still
remember when that song came on I've
never done I've never seen because I was
sitting next to the Moon all the time
I've never seen anyone do like the slow
turn
because I was just like I know the song
mood I was like yeah me too and then the
chorus you know comes on like the
singing and we both just
[Music]
is this for real
I'm not imagining this am I no it was
epic though it was I think I think that
was like a great song to pick regardless
of like the name status yeah I mean we
picked it for us we didn't pick it for
no it's a great choice